on sait qu'on vit avec le co vide mais
bon là on nous le s'enfonça dans la tête
du matin jusqu'au soir
c'est un peu stressant quand même et on
a l'impression qu'il n'ya plus rien
d'autre qui se passe dans le monde s'est
terminée tôt que c'est bien ça nous
tient informés de l'actualité
et non je pense que c'est important
parce que les personnes sont plus
vulnérables que d'autres pour faire
attention
on sait bien qu'ils ne tiennent informés
tous les jours à la télé c'est sûr que
ça peut être un peu envahissant c'est
vrai que moi pendant le premier
confinement j'en ai eu un peu ras-le-bol
du surplus de l'information parce que on
sait plus distinguer quelles sont les
vraies informations des fausses celle
d'actualité au nom et c'est vrai que
c'est on a du mal à se repérer là dedans
dans on est un peu perdu quoi ça que
c'est un peu délicat surtout moi j'ai
peur pour les personnes âgées par
exemple qui ne savent pas forcément
utiliser les médias correctement et qui
peuvent être
un peu stressée par rapport à sa
situation et avoir du mal à se
renseigner ou à tomber sur des fausses
informations faut en parler c'est quand
on voit quand même que les chiffres
augmentent donc
il faut que les médias en parlent après
faut pas non plus tomber dans la
psychose donc je pense que je pense quoi
c'est un juste milieu
en fait sur le corps d'un virus depuis
des mois on raconte parfois n'importe
quoi les informations on a dû une
information qui arrive aujourd'hui dans
quelques jours on va voir qu'elle n'est
pas ce n'est pas exact donc je crois
qu'il faut laisser les scientifiques qui
sont franchement dans le métier parler
du sujet après évidemment
certes il ya beaucoup d'informations sur
locaux vides je ne peux pas dire c'est
beaucoup trop
parce que c'est le sujet actuel dont la
vie des gens dépend mais aussi
l'économie la société
c'est pas quelque chose qui va partir
demain son décès un impact considérable
sur notre les années à venir
donc c'est important d'en parler mais
aussi peut-être parler du côté
économique et des choses qui vont suivre
par la suite on n'est pas assez d'être
précise sur cette question d'un trop
c'est toujours trop mais en réalité tout
le monde attend des informations
complémentaires pour savoir si vraiment
bon sourd on va être confiné soit il ya
un miracle qui arrive dans le traitement
voilà donc ils en font trop mais d'un
autre côté quoi faire d'autres puces et
c'est le fond de commerce aussi des
chaînes 1 donc je pense qu'il ya
d'autres sujets d'un traité et on a trop
d'informations sur le corona virus et du
conte c'est même pas ce qui se passe
ailleurs en fait on est on est
monopolisée sur ceux sur le sujet ont
pas sûrement côté d'informations
importantes sur d'autres pays ou même en
france ce qui se passe actuellement
trouve qu'on est assez bien informés
par contre les sujets sont peut-être un
petit peu répétitif on est bien informé
peut-être trop trop souvent la même
chose globalement je trouve que les
sujets sont trop répétitif donc les
médias ne font peut-être pas trop mais
elle devrait peut-être mieux cibler de
façon à ce qu'on ait une information on
va dire régulière mais qui apportent des
choses nouvelles à chaque fois alors que
là on a l'impression quand même un bon
nombre de fois
surtout dans la presse télévisuelle que
on a la même information retraités du
matin jusqu'au soir